[Applause]
[Music]
what a show we got in store you know why
because it's on drugs
i mean the topic is about drugs i can't
say if the panelists are all on drugs
but let's just say the dogs hired by
security to sniff for contraband started
humping cats book bag
and then passed out from a contact high
r.i.p dogs
but first
harris faulkner is back
i wonder i wonder what she could be
happy about
i'm happy about this because just 15
minutes ago the tattoo that i had of
greg gutfeld on my thing
like lower side like by my knee by my
name it's gone
bye greg you think i would not include
that in the show harris
my husband now has to see that twice yes
well
at least you didn't get the tattoo you
know who did get the tattoo stuart
varney and he's not complaining
all right
also uh brian kilmeade is back
obviously
obviously somebody canceled
yeah we tried everybody including the
janitor with the lazy eye
but
and and and then i'm very excited we got
a first-time guest dr carl hart
carl is a professor of psychology at
columbia relaxed cat he doesn't do
outpatients
uh
dr dr hart where's that book dr hart
wrote one of the bravest books you're
gonna find drug use for grown-ups oh
there it is
uh that was my major at berkeley
i still can't believe you didn't ask me
to write the forward
so the book is about legalizing drugs it
might piss some of you off but that's
what the drugs are for
but the book isn't just about legalizing
the easy ones like pot or mushrooms or
the window cleaner that cat mixes with
gatorade
but heroin
now this is when people say no no no not
heroin look what that drug does the lost
souls on the streets haunting city
corners like ghostly zombies living for
a fix that's true we indeed have
problems but here's the deal that's
happening while the drugs are illegal
yet they're easier to get than kovid
even my cat
even my cat is dealing drugs
could have been more subtle
[Laughter]
yep while we pour billions into a drug
war not unlike afghanistan we just keep
getting our ass kicked we fund other
countries militaries to fight the drug
trade then let anyone walk across the
border with a bindle up their butt
it's more counterproductive than a broom
that shoots glitter
in 2019 over 70 000 people died from
overdoses in the u.s that's 70 000 more
people than have read killmeade's new
book
[Laughter]
make a joke about drug death
but during
during the pandemic that number exploded
probably because we were all trapped
inside watching cnn
but what is causing this wave of death
don't blame prescription opioids because
as we cut down on that the death rates
skyrocket no to no today overdoses are
driven by fentanyl and like the
coronavirus and cheap patio furniture
it's made in china it comes through our
southern border and it's mixed into
other street drugs to kick it up a notch
it's basically a hamburger helper for
junkies
tell us lara logan
with the pandemic hit we realized oh
without china we got no antibiotics
right no medical equipment so what did
they do to change that
nothing right and when china got all
that capability that's how they found
the analogues for fentanyl which they
then introduced as a street drug made a
deal with the mexican cartels and now
they've got what how many americans are
dying yes every year and we hear nothing
about it i mean go to san francisco
nobody cares that you got people
standing on the street pissing on
themselves and you know and defecating
everywhere you know and uh unable to
function and what do they say well let's
reduce the mandatory minimum sentencing
for fentanyl that's what the bible
administration justice department is
working on right now
so during 12 months of the pandemic
nearly a hundred thousand americans have
died from ods that's a 30 jump experts
blame it on the stay-at-home orders i
don't buy it because when it comes to
this stuff the government is like our
president's underpants
full of
crap i feel bad just saying that
but especially when it comes to health
it's true remember the nutrition pyramid
it was everywhere
classrooms waiting rooms the shed where
i keep the au pair
but also cereal boxes yeah imagine that
a box of carbs says you should stuff
your face with carbs
sadly my chart had a typo and i was
eating 30 pounds of crabs a month
but a cereal company telling you to eat
more carbs it's like the diamond
industry telling you how many months
salary you should spend on an engagement
ring
we thought we were following the science
but we should have been following the
money cookie crisp had parents thinking
kids started their day right by eating a
bowl of cookies
it's amazing
it's like those stories about fake
doctors tricking women into physical
checkups that's what this is
and yes i stopped doing it years ago
they
they repossessed my van
but this chart was dead wrong and deadly
you had processed carbs in huge
quantities turning healthy kids into
mini bryant stelters
right now our adult obesity rate is 42
up from 34
just 10 years earlier the only thing
rising faster is our blood sugar so
what's that got to do with drugs well
the same people who lied about food are
lying about drugs right now when the
government or media reports ods just
like the crime stats they never get
specific they never tell the whole truth
it's about illegal fentanyl not
prescription drugs and it's not
overdoses it's poisonings people buy
drugs with fentanyl in it and they die
peop including people that you know from
tom petty to michael k williams to
athletes and actors but the people you
heard of dying of opiate overdoses it's
actually fentanyl poisoning not
prescriptions but a poisoned used to
kill people deliberately it's the
biggest story you aren't hearing because
all you hear is the word overdoses and
the worst part of this
patients who rely on legal opioids for
cancer pain and other diseases can't get
them because we've conflated safe drugs
with fentanyl but that's pretending two
totally different things are the same
like cnn and news
long way for a joke
when it's really actually terrorism and
it drives legal users to illegal stuff
and they die because they can't control
the dosage or like hot dogs they just
don't know what's in it imagine you
could only buy cigarettes illegally but
one cigarette had a thousand times the
nicotine you would die or at least sound
like cat
but instead you go to any market and buy
a carton in san francisco they even let
you take it but the dosage is controlled
meanwhile stats show addiction is
actually rare among prescription opioids
and overdoses are nearly impossible to
find i bet you didn't know that because
we're operating on the lie of all drugs
bad and punish the law abiding here's an
analogy you'll understand what's the
biggest complaint by gun owners
no it's not that the gun jams when
watching the view
it's that the laws it's that the laws
punish the law abiding while doing
nothing about illegal guns fueling
street violence it's the same argument
here we punish the law-abiding and let
the lawless kill we'll even provide
clean needles so it's the spike drugs
they die from
but sadly we target the decent person
who administers drugs safely in a safe
environment like a doctor's office or
cat's apartment
but it's time we stop this death
it's also time to let people seek the
relief they choose and if they don't
hurt anyone then it's nobody's business
everyone on this planet has a right to
relief whether it's a martini a joint or
an opiate because frankly i'm tired of
buying clean urine from steve ducey
but if you need any dm me
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight's yes
she's on your fox news screens more than
relief factor host of the faulkner focus
and outnumbered co-host harris faulkner
he loves his wardrobe for the same
reason he loves soccer lots of boring
ties boxer frank's coast and author of
the new book the president and the
freedom fighter brian kilmee
he's an air force veteran and an expert
on flying high columbia university
psychology professor dr carl hart
and she's 90 pounds soaking wet probably
from all those spilled drinks boston's
contributor catch him
your audience is incredible i've never
heard him this loud
that was amazing we uh uh in the spirit
of the show we drug them
by the way a lot of people don't know
this about the original fox and friends
uh but the segment cooking with friends
right right it was your idea but it was
about meth
right
right that that's a good that's a very
good trivia note and that was only you
if you interviewed our staff there's
only the way you'd know that yes okay
what did i convince you in any shape or
form
of with my monologue did you cause i i
assume that you probably are
anti-legalization
i have not done it as heavily researched
as as your teleprompter did but i will
but
but but i will say and like the
professor but but i will say
fundamentally i don't think it's good to
legalize uh terrible behavior but the
counter argument would be oh well you
have alcohol alcohol's out there is an
alcohol a drug my sense is the big story
in in that story was what china's doing
i tried to sell it to him that way i
know that the i know that you'd only be
into it if i blame chyna who are you
talking
you have you have a panel here and you
look past the panel who are you talking
to i was talking
sometimes i talk to me oh okay fine you
were looking at the monitor yeah yeah
that picture is in the monitor so what's
out of the rest of it what did you
realize
what i realized look at his book look at
his book
white man on the top black man on the
bottom
what racist
you are a racist
all right i got to move on i'm tired no
no no no thank you applaud
[Applause]
wow all right
all right
uh you're not going to amend that
statement
you act like we agree with that that's
not true whatever you do either whatever
you do in your private time is up to you
i want to get the professor in because
he's how would you respond like he he
brought up the alcohol thing and there's
this theory that you can only have one
bad thing be legal right but uh what's
your take on that
i don't know alcohol is bad is that a
bad thing well i'm saying to counter to
my argument fundamentally i don't think
legalizing heroin and all these drugs
this elite the the drugs that are legal
now are going to be productive and the
counterargument to my statement is well
alcohol isn't that technically a drug
isn't that addictive i get it but to me
if you legalize all these drugs tell me
a place where it works i i don't think i
i don't think we're we're saying
legalized we're talking about legally
regulating so that means that adults
have access to these activities whether
it's drugs whether it's driving an
automobile whether it's owning a gun
adults have
access to these activities and how would
that affect the people sleeping on the
street
uh what do you mean can you go get more
of them or less
the people sleeping on the street
streets
most of those people are not there
because of drugs i know that's the
popular thing for people to say
most of those people are there because
they're having financial problems
because of mental health issues but it's
easy to blame drugs that's what we do in
this country we blame drugs for all of
our sort of ills
that's not that's that's not what's
going on you've been living in the city
though right
yeah so the city over the last six
months mentally ill are populating most
of what we're seeing right now and on
this panel right yeah absolutely i want
to get here excluding harris
you're looking at two different
categories of drugs though because what
the doctor is talking about legalizing
like you would alcohol or something like
that you're talking about regulating the
age of people who can use a certain drug
that's already considered a controlled
substance but people are dying from
fentanyl because they're buying it off
the street they think is xanax what they
think right and they're and some of them
are doing it because those substances
are hard to get right now because
they're not regulated yes and where
china comes into play and where because
i don't need the telephone yeah um
where china comes into play is right at
the nexus of where mexico is feasting
like scorpions at our border off those
people who want to try to get into here
illegally and using them as coyotes
a lot of that problem would be solved if
drugs were legalized here there would be
no demand for the supply that the car
took and and perhaps controlling your
borders all adults that wanted to do
these things i don't think that you can
say you live in a free country if you
don't own your own body and they're
putting fentanyl not just in they're
putting it in cocaine they're putting it
everywhere trying to do cocaine wants to
fall asleep that's why they're doing
cocaine
so may i say
one thing one thing about fentanyl it's
important for us to know that fentanyl
has been a legal drug in the united
states since the 1960s and it's an
important drug in terms of pain reliever
it's it's prescribed to treat moderate
to severe pain and it's an excellent
drug as long as people understand that
they have fentanyl the problem is when
people don't understand that they have
fentanyl
they may take too much of it and
overdose because they'll take examples
not knowing that fentanyl which as you
say is as powerful as morphine
and gives you the same kind of high
that's why they use it to lace it to
make those it's more potent than
morphine it's a lot more potent than
morphine but the problem the thing is
nobody really wants to mix their cocaine
even people who are selling
cocaine they don't want to mix their
cocaine with fentanyl these things
happen accidentally
but
there are easy fixes to this just like
they do in europe we can have these
things called drug checking uh truck
checking facility allows people to
submit small samples of their drugs and
then they get a chemical printout and
then if fentanyl is in it then we
everyone knows that fentanyl is in it
and you don't take it or you scale back
how much you take we have the technology
in this country to make these things
available we haven't made them available
to the public because
uh we don't care yeah you know i have i
have an alternative i just have a you
know cause i'm you're fairly well off i
just have a drug tester oh yeah so i i
just give it to them and if they fall
down i don't take it is that like a food
tester yes exactly all right we got to
move on